une journée pour soutenir les start up
était organisée ce jeudi 1er décembre à
jouy en josas hec paris a accueilli la
deuxième édition du paris saclay invest
le concept l'événement organisé deux
fois par an permet de mettre en relation
les jeunes entreprises du territoire
avec des investisseurs le fait
d'organiser à deux reprises dans l'année
cet événement effectivement permet
d'accompagner déjà détecté les start up
et qu'il ya de nombreuses créations
d'entreprises innovantes sur le
territoire
cet événement permet de détecter et de
les aider à trouver leur financement
sur les quarante dossiers
présélectionnés dix ont été retenus pour
être présentés devant les investisseurs
parmi les startups on retrouve moon à
une entreprise créée en juin dernier qui
a trouvé une idée pour lutter contre les
insomnies s'est basé sur des études
médicales qui montre le lien très fort
entre température et sommeil et le fait
que notre température pour s'endormir a
besoin de diminuer quand on n'arrive pas
sans heurts parfois on retrouve lauriers
on cherche on cherche la fraîcheur donc
baser sur ces faits on développe un
produit qui permet de suivre le sommeil
et réguler la température de la tête
grâce à l'oreille et donc du corps en
fonction des besoins
autre projet retenu celui de piques
sprint une start up basée à versailles
la firme propose de créer sa propre
carte postale avec ses photos et de
l'imprimé instantanément via son
smartphone cet été en vacances parce que
tout simplement j'ai cherché des cartes
postales
j'en trouvais pas qu'il me satisfaisait
aujourd'hui beaucoup de karpatt at on
assez kitsch et j'étais à côté d'un ami
qui envoyait lui-même ses propres photos
sur les réseaux sociaux et je me dis que
l'idée
ce que pouvoir envoyer moi mes photos
sont des cartes postales que j'aurais
exactement le la carte postale que je
voulais envoyer à ce moment là c'est
finalement l'entreprise 13h qui a reçu
le prix du jury la start up a mis en
place un logiciel pour aider au
diagnostic du génome humain
une troisième édition sera organisée en
2017 dans les yvelines pour le moment
aucune date ni aucun lieu n'ont été
défini